just so you know before she comes she's
uh someone you kinda have to get used to
wasn't that me hey guys hey you ready to
go yep
how's it yeah and what this no oh gotta
be kidding me right
oh my god I can't even believe I made it
here seriously first Mike Harmon start
huh my neighbor just like piles all his
trash into my trash can I have this
whole bag of recycling I recycle and I
couldn't even fit in there was
ridiculous I'm missing day with this
happy birthday thank you okay so that
just about wraps Adele actually I have a
few questions
oh my god Melanie did he tell you about
that time he got really really drunk and
wet his pants and everybody saw and he
cried no no okay don't tell me that you
that I look at Melanie saying oh what do
you want me to be nice and honest
where is a food seriously in like 20
minutes
no yeah it's been forever seriously are
you guys seeing this this is ridiculous
come on I can't make this stuff up I
gotta get back to work
yo do you want to go to the movies I
want to be outside today Beach I don't
like fan Gator Park
crap you want to just stay in no that's
so boring that'll be ten dollars please
ten dollars that's expensive just
staying
[Music]
this oh yes I'm so hungry
[Music]